i
[Música]
ah
la pandemia golpeó fuerte prácticamente
a toda la economía argentina según el
indicador mensual de la actividad
económica de julio de 2020 el más
reciente publicado por el instituto
nacional de estadística y censos casi
todos los 16 sectores que mide sufrieron
caídas el que más cayó fue la pesca con
una disminución de casi 70 por ciento de
su actividad seguido por hoteles y
restaurantes con más del 65 por ciento
de caída y un rubro clave por su
capacidad de rápida generación de empleo
el de la construcción se contrajo más de
un 30 por ciento de todos modos es
posible que hayan empezado a recuperarse
al menos algunos de ellos con la
progresiva apertura de la cuarentena que
se ha dado hasta ahora pero los efectos
han sido en muchos casos irreversibles
de acuerdo con una estimación de la
cámara argentina de comercio justamente
hasta julio de este año habían cerrado
más de 42 mil pequeños y medianas
empresas
[Música]
en ecuador del cob y 19 ha puesto al
país andino en un abismo económico en
una economía que ya presentaba una
situación descendente desde hace dos
años según el académico y exministro de
finanzas carlos de la torre la caída del
producto interno bruto y de los
indicadores sociales se tradujeron en la
pérdida de un millón de empleos y
calificaciones negativas para el país
andino 70 por ciento del aparato
productivo deberá recuperarse de las
paralizaciones según el especialista
200000 desafiliaciones del seguro social
se produjeron en ecuador donde el
turismo el comercio la producción
industrial el sector hotelero son los
más afectados por la pandemia en medio
de ello un nuevo préstamo el fondo
monetario internacional- por 6 mil 500
millones de dólares considerado
insuficiente a cinco meses de elecciones
generales lo que compromete el próximo
gobierno a realizar fuertes reformas
tributarias otras estimaciones el
académico de la universidad central de
ecuador jhon cajas guijarro aseguran que
el país no se recuperará hasta el año
[Música]
en perú todavía no existe una cantidad
exacta de empresas que se declararon en
quiebra por la pandemia del cobre y 19
se señala que el sector turismo es el
más afectado los representantes afirman
que más de 50 mil empresas dejaron de
operar paralelamente en más del 30 por
ciento de negocios optaron por un giro
de bienes y servicios para poder
sobrevivir pero los que tuvieron mejor
suerte en no le están pasando nada bien
estadísticas oficiales revelan que en
lima casi 7 de cada 10 empresas que
lograron reiniciar sus actividades
sufren por las bajas ventas ante esta
situación crítica el gobierno peruano
impulsó un plan de más de 17 mil
millones de dólares para brindar
créditos bancarios a las compañías
afectadas por el largo confinamiento las
autoridades afirman que más de 477 mil
empresas accedieron a la ayuda del
denominado bono reactiva perú pero
diversos sindicatos denuncian que el
rescate estatal beneficiaría a empresas
de grandes capitales que despidieron a
sus trabajadores sin respetar el
principio de la ayuda del gobierno que
prioriza mantener el pago de salarios de
los empleados
[Música]